i don't know if you've read carl jung
said
that the greatest danger that humanity
faces is not from any external force
like natural disasters or
diseases or pandemics he said the
greatest danger that humanity faces
is collective psychosis
so to some extent i see it happening
not quite as extreme yet as in
places like maoist china or cambodia
where
um one-third of the population got
murdered in companies
absurd totally absurd ideas taking over
people's minds for example in cambodia
um we were there a few years ago
the at the time of pol pot the
cambodian mad dictator
um anybody who could uh
read and write or anybody if you wear
glasses you were an
enemy of the people because you were
regarded as the oppressor
and likely to be killed if you had to
show your hands and did
you well oh you're not doing manual work
you're one of
you you're one of the enemies of the
people
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the most widely recognized
spiritual
teachers on the planet his book the
power of now
sold 12 million that's million copies
and the follow-up a new earth sold
over 15 million copies both have been
translated in over 50 languages my
friend eckhart tolle
welcome back to the reuben report thank
you dave nice to see you again
it's great to talk to you uh as my
audience knows we are at the beginning
of august right now and i am technically
off the grid i am in an undisclosed
location with no
technology no phone no computer no
news no nothing so we're taping this at
the end of july and i thought you would
be the right person to
sort of kick this month off with so
before we get to sort of the off the
grid stuff
and and digital detox i wanted to ask
you just sort of what do you make of the
the spiritual health of the planet
in this last year and a half this sort
of crazy
year and a half that we've all had to
deal with
uh yes uh i believe crazy
is a quite good word to describe it
in many ways there's been
many collective challenges the main one
is the
virus and the lockdowns
uh and various other challenges
um i've had this strange feeling idea
in the past few months
that a certain segment of humanity
is uh
losing the ability to think rationally
there's a decrease in whether
i call it iq or whatever it may be
there is a diminishment of rational
faculty
as reflected in many ways on
the mainstream media social media and so
on
and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware
more aware more conscious is not drawn
into the regressive
phase that some of humanity may be going
through
it's not unusual for humanity to
occasionally
collectively regress to a lower state of
consciousness it has happened
whenever a country or collective has
been taken over
by an almost one could say
toxic ideology that has completely
taken possession of millions of people's
minds
look at of course national national
socialism in germany
the maoist cultural revolution was quite
crazy what happened in cambodia under
polapod
totally crazy ideas invaded
millions of people's minds and
reduced their ability to to actually
engage in
rational thinking and
things that happened for example in
maoist china during the cultural
revolution
children reporting on their parents when
they were angry with their parents all
they had to do is go to school and
report their parents if they had said
something against the
government the parents would be taken
away never seen again
they they went around public parks in
big cities in china tearing out flowers
out of because
beauty with regards as bourgeois you
have to kill your
back your pets your your dogs and cats
totally and these are just a few
examples of
totally toxic and
irrational thoughts taking over people's
minds
so that's to some extent i've been
seeing this
happening collectively not just in one
country in quite a few western
many western countries that i'm aware of
and but it has not affected everybody
some people have managed to remain aware
they have not been
one could say infected by
what one could perhaps call a a mental
virus or mental viruses
that reduce people's ability
to actually see reality reality then
gets distorted through the veil
of these mental viruses that have taken
over people's minds
this is um more serious
more serious pandemic than anything that
happens on the physical
level as far as um pandemics are
concerned the actual viruses
actually you might i don't know if
you've read
carl jung said that the greatest danger
that humanity faces is not from
any external force like natural
disasters
or diseases or pandemics
he said the greatest danger that
humanity faces
is collective psychosis
so to some extent i see it happening not
quite as
extreme yet as in places like maoist
china or cambodia where
um one third of the population got
murdered
absurd totally absurd ideas taking over
people's minds for example in cambodia
we were there a few years ago
the at the time of pol pot the
cambodian mad dictator
um anybody who could uh
read and write or anybody if you wear
glasses you were an enemy of the people
because you were regarded as the
oppressor
and likely to be killed if you had to
show your hands and did you well
oh you're not doing manual work you're
one of you
you're one of the enemies of the people
that send them away got killed
one third or more of the population got
uh exterminated through
insanity taking over people's minds
um to some extra that you no longer can
see reality as it is the famous example
from
1984 or well um
you have to believe that two plus two
equals five
and uh if you don't believe it then you
are the
you are the enemy which is sort of what
we're being told these days
from uh some some pretty powerful people
and some pretty
powerful people that are pushing bad
ideas but i i suspect that you think if
more
people lived in the moment if more
people
harness the power of now that that would
be the best inoculation from this mind
virus
yes inoculation or
to have um
an inoculation is one word you could one
could use the key
is uh immunity i think i would use
immunity
the key is what we could call
awareness or i sometimes call it
presence awareness it says
awareness of presence is nothing
complicated or uh it's the ability
to become aware of your thoughts
uh so you can take a step back and
observe what thoughts are going through
your head for example
when this ability arises i call that the
beginning of a spiritual awakening
spiritual is no longer being
completely trapped and identified with
the movement of thinking
this is particularly important now the
danger of um
infection viral infection on the mental
level
has always been there but it's now
becoming
magnified by the technology that we now
have
a toxic idea a toxic thought
can spread like wildfire through the
internet
within a few days and can
take possession or become lodged
in countless people's minds and once a
thought is become
lodged then it will attract associated
thoughts that resonate with it
and then suddenly you see
reality through the veil of
of that irrational thinking but you
don't know that this is happening
because you do not have the immunity of
awareness
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell